here would be the first to admit that
when it comes to kind of oratorical
oratorical
heights he's never going to be barack
obama but i thought it was a very very
good conference speech what i like to
see in a in a party conference speech is
a
leader who
seems to be comfortable in his own skin
who's speaking to the country even
though he's having to do it through the
party
and where there is a real sense of
values
and a sense of what that person is in
relation to what he wants to do for the
country and i thought that came through
i thought that i thought he told a lot
about himself but in a way that related
to why he's in politics what he wants to
do in politics and i do think the
contrast with boris johnson we will come
across very clearly to people like look
i i actually think boris johnson is a
bad person uh but i thought it was an
interesting line of attack from kier to
say
it's not that he's a bad person he's a
trivial person and i think that what you
saw through the speech and what we're
seeing you know across the debate every
day
is we're facing some really really big
serious challenges and we don't have a
serious prime minister
and a serious government and kirsten was
saying that's what i would bring and you
know i thought as a conference speech i
thought it worked very very well was
there enough substance there because
obviously he's trying to paint himself
as a credible opponent to the prime
minister and he know he did bash boris
johnson and you know said what you
reiterated there but was that enough to
win people over in terms of was there
enough substance in his speech about
what labour would do labor policies how
they plan to improve people's lives
i think i actually think there was you
know for a for a party conference speech
there wasn't that much knocking of um of
his opponents and i thought what
knocking there was was was was fairly
effective
and i think that it's always very
difficult with the conference speech
even with one as as long as that and i
think with all the applause and the
standing ovations it came to something
close to an hour and a half as long as a
football match and you know you're
trying to you're speaking to the party
you're trying to keep get the party to
move in a certain direction but most
importantly you're trying to speak to
the country now what the country i'm not
going to listen to
is a kind of shopping list of then we'll
do this and then we'll do this and then
we'll do this i think you want to give a
sense of who and what you are and what
are the big things that you want to do
so for example somebody like me who
works in the mental health advocacy
field that was music to my ears there'll
be a lot of people like that that he
really was putting mental health there
something like education he was putting
out a sense of what the policy direction
is going to be and he was making some
pretty big commitments there likewise on
on the on the climate crisis and so
forth so you're putting out priorities
you're saying the kind of direction
you're going in
but i think you did that well without
you becoming a sort of you know a policy
shopping list so i certainly think it
was a very substantial speech
and a serious speech and for enough i
think the hecklers that you mentioned i
think they played into his hands because
the one thing the public want to know
when they rejected a party in elections
wrongly as they were rejected two years
ago they want to know that party's
listening and they're going to change a
bit and you know if you've got people
saying don't change don't dare change
and here's the saying you shout what we
want we are changing that's a very
positive message for the country i think
he was very ambitious wasn't he saying
that he thought that labour could be the
conservatives at the next general
election
and in doing that
he tackled all the major topics that
people are thinking about now the fuel
crisis
future of social care mental health
provision you touched on there education
he said he was tempted to to mention it
three times he resisted um
do you think that is too high in
ambition or with what he delivered today
will the labour party have a sense of
actually yes we can
well they should do because
the fact look the the last election was
a was a disaster and it's a it's a long
way to come back from that but i do
think we're living in very volatile
times i do think this government is
absolutely there for the taking i think
boris johnson is emerging as the worst
possible prime minister for this country
at the worst possible time he's got a
cabinet full of people that are there
because they're loyal to him or because
they're willing to repeat all the
nonsense and the lies that he tells
about brexit and everything else and the
labour party is the only other party
that can win now it's going to be a very
very tough challenge and he knows that
but i think actually what has to happen
now in a way i thought that was the you
know in a sense i understand that kobe's
made it difficult but that was really i
think the start of something there today
and what has to happen now i think is
that he and the labor party have to show
the kind of energy and the kind of
commitment and the kind of fight that
they've been showing in the last few
days the public have now got to see that
day after day after day after day
because you do not win general elections
when it comes to a campaign you win a
general election
during the parliament not at the end of
it and i think from for me
even with all i accept covert has been
difficult as i say but even with all
that for me the labour front bench has
not been nearly energetic enough not
been nearly proactive enough and not
campaigning enough you've got a campaign
all the time and i think if you could
take that energy that was there today
and take the messaging that was there
today and turn it into non-stop
campaigning against what i think is a
pretty hopeless government i think labor
does have a chance but be realistic
there's no point going around saying we
are going to win you've got to say we
want to win we can win but here's all
the things we have to do yeah what
should be the focus now you talk about
campaigning and really as you mentioned
with covid a lot of people saying where
is shakir stamina our new labour leader
in his defense you know it was locked
down it was coving he wasn't as visible
as he would have been
under normal circumstances so where do
you want to see him he can't focus on
everything what should he focus on
in the next few months
well i think he
he actually answered that in the speech
i thought he when he talked about
you can you good society you can't have
the good society without the strong
economy you can't have a strong economy
without the good society now that is
that's what i call a framing message
so what does the good society mean what
does the strong economy mean how do we
get that i thought he spoke very well
about how co would expose weaknesses
that have been there for too long i was
pleased that he linked even though
johnson's terrible he actually said this
is about a decade of conservative role
so focus on the weaknesses that have
been exposed and how you as leader of
the labour party of the labour party are
going to address those and actually you
say you can't do everything
it's true you can't do everything all of
the time but you can be engaged every
single day on one of the big challenges
that he set out there today and i think
it's important that now that he becomes
much more visible than he's been that
the shadow cabinet becomes much more
visible that the front bench becomes
much more visible because frankly you
know in the last year or so and caveat
of course if the government's if there's
a national crisis the government is
going to take
center stage all of the time but
actually i think as we come out of the
pandemic as we now witness the disasters
that brexit is unleashing upon upon the
country
david lambie said interviewed david
lammy on television this morning on good
morning britain and he said i think
we're getting into something more like
normal politics well normal politics
means the opposition has to be out there
or big things and big issues every
single day